coming up is uh Kevin oconnell set to
join us time he is okay the Vikings head
coach Vikings are five and four and uh
they beat the Falcons so they host the
Saints this Sunday at the Broncos host
the Bears at the Raiders all right you
got some wins in there it's been a crazy
season so far let me start with
something that's totally away from your
football resume how uh aware were your
friends that your dad was an FBI agent
growing up and did that prevent them
from hanging out with
you I believe they were aware um but I'd
like to think I did not have a Bronco uh
like Paulie um and uh but uh I I think
they were aware but it didn't prevent
them uh he had a way of kind of
disarming them their fears of wir TAPS
and things like that um you know maybe I
did think twice every now and then
before I would have a Gathering of
friends when my parents were out of town
I can tell you that what did he do with
the FBI he did all kinds of stuff Dan he
did uh all kinds of stuff I'm very proud
of him you're keeping it vague but in
true uh Family Fashion I'm Gonna Keep It
vague tell me how you kind of kept the
confusion away from Josh JBS when you
know you have to put him in and he
doesn't even know the names of his
teammates so what is your job in that
moment yeah it was uh you know so we
have some ways in our offense where it
might seem crazy um to to folks to say
how is this guy that's been here five
days uh using the no huddle and and
giving you know giving cues to his
teammates you know going fast but really
on that last drive that was probably the
easiest it was all day because the coach
the quarterback system um really stays
open almost the whole time if you're uh
up until the snap if you're above 15
seconds on the play clock so that was
probably the easiest all day and that
was probably when he was at his most uh
comfortable you know moment in the game
just because he had had reps he had had
some success he' kind of found a good
balance with using his legs and working
through some progressions um but we you
know we we had it set up going in that
if he went in the game there were some
some plays that maybe he felt better uh
than others from the complete menu that
jiren hall went into the game with um
there was only probably I tend to go
Rogue sometimes Dan and and and start
calling something that the guys maybe
hadn't seen since training camp there
was only a couple of those where I had
to explain to him what I was saying I
said you know hey just say this out loud
and here's what it means type of thing
um but uh once again I think this this
story is about joshh dos I think it's
about his ability to use why we wanted
to bring him in here was the experience
over starting uh you know nine games and
and playing in any offense you know the
beauty of that is you've at least played
against NFL defenses he had played
against Sam Fran he had played against
the Giants he had played against some
good defenses where the speed of the
Game Wouldn't overwhelm him so I tried
to make the moments in between snaps uh
you know just giving him Clarity on the
things that I would think of if I was in
there okay I I remember what that play
meant but wait which side is that on
which side's that on hey this is on your
left you're going to have you know a
corner and a flat over there you know an
in cut and your checkdowns out there in
the flat like stuff like that where um
you know just give him a pain of picture
quickly in seven to8 seconds and then
let him just go play well plus he's a
very bright guy when when when you
decide if you want to be an astronaut or
an NFL quarterback I think he chose
wisely there but so you're talking to
him the whole time in in his headset and
and I would just call you know I would
call the play or give him a wristband
number um and then just watch him and
watch him walk into the Huddle uh call
the play and the second I saw those guys
say ready break I started talking again
just as he walked to the line of
scrimmage
uh and that's just a credit to another
thing for Josh how fast he got the guys
in and out of the Huddle um not knowing
some of their names might have helped
because then he could just say you know
call the play Ready break and he didn't
have to you know I know uh I've seen
some movie scenes where you know the
quarterback's calling guys out by their
names and hey I need you to run this
route you're on the button hook and
you're doing this um it was not like
that because he would have not known
most of the guys in the Huddle but um it
was it was it was fun for me it was the
closest thing that I felt like being on
the field at least mentally with the
with the quarterback uh you know since I
got those uh really impactful snaps as a
player that I did what's what's your
most impactful snap that you remember
when you
played um I remember the most impactful
on me is I remember getting you know we
we had a very successful game when I was
in New England against the Cardinals
late in the year it was about 20 degrees
and I remember getting put in the game
when we were up late
Cardinals eventually went on to be in
the Super Bowl that year but um I I went
in there late it was about 20 degrees I
couldn't feel my hands and I uh rolled
out to pass uh threw about a 20 yard you
know comeback on the sideline to ma to
Matthew Slater one of my best friends
and uh went right through his Frozen
hands and then Darnell docket hit me so
hard that I my face was completely
covered in snot and uh that was probably
the most impactful um if I'm being
honest but uh no just I just remember
what it was like to be you know come off
the bench come off in in moments and
have to walk in there and things happen
really really fast so uh you know just
as much as I could put Josh at ease the
other day and then rely on his
experience I think I gave him the
coaching Point probably 10 times at the
end of a lot of just uh you know hey do
this do that do this but it was always
don't forget about using your legs don't
forget they got to defend you um mainly
on those critical third Downs or you
know some of those plays that he made
that really were gamechanging
game-winning plays like that fourth and
seven scramble to kind of set up the
touchdown pass towards the end talking
to Kevin okono the Vikings head coach
how much can you learn from Brady by
just watching him and and can you
simulate that emulate that when you go
out on the field yeah I think uh I I
I've kind of seen it from a lot of guys
over the years you know whether it was
trying to emulate Brady or even even to
me you know sometimes I'll watch Jordan
love and I'll see him take a rep and it
looks like Aaron roders or even Zack
Wilson now you know even the limited
time he was around Aon you can see that
and I think that's what you know good
quarterbacks try to do um when they're
with someone of you know that nature a
Hall of Fame caliber quarterback they're
like that for a reason um but it's not
just how they play Dan it's what they do
Monday through Saturday to prepare um
it's what they do you know how they
interact with their teammates how they
lead how they you know I I my my whole
experience in New England really kind of
shaped my whole football Journey because
uh I probably wasn't mentally at that
place coming out of you know San Diego
State where I could absorb that whole
offense so much running through the
quarterback so much responsibility um
but I certainly tried to learn it and it
kind of set a foundation for me uh
throughout my football journey of uh an
unbelievable
uh starting point of yeah I might not
have been you know the best possible
version of myself as a player in those
moments and there's a thousand things I
could have done better but there's very
few days that go by that I don't think
about something um how to apply it as a
coach now either being around coach
bellich being around Tom being around a
lot of un you know that roster in 2008
and 2009 in New England I mean you you
can name the brushies and the rulls
Rodney Harrison Randy Moss Wes Welker um
Vince wilfor I mean there were guys that
I just remember they might not have
known me very well but I was I was
obviously very observant of those guys
and unbelievable opportunity you know
for the journey that I would eventually
go on now as a coach to look back on
that and and uh be able to apply a lot
of things that I learned would you uh
give up your Healthy Achilles to give to
Kirk Cousins if it meant that he would
be able to play this season I absolutely
would um and I don't think the folks
down at uh uh you know Lifetime Fitness
would worry too much about losing me on
the basketball court this off season um
they would find somebody else to step in
but I I absolutely would do that Dan
when when do you know that he's blown
out as
Achilles I uh I kind of I kind of knew
pretty quickly just you know watching
him you know react to uh you know how it
how is how he kind of went down and I
was shocked that he was able to he
climbed up in the pock in and it
actually happened when his back foot hit
um and the way he went down I kind of
knew and then uh you know as he as he
got to the sideline I went over and just
you know you you you pretty much knew
how how he described it he thought he
had been you know somebody had either
hit him in the back of the leg and and
clearly there wasn't anybody around him
at the time um so I kind of knew and uh
you know that was that was a tough
moment that Kurt Cousins was playing as
well as anybody in our league and uh it
was kind of my vision for him um and he
did unbelievable things last year he
played the position at a high level last
year but where he was at and just
knowing some of the things that we were
asking him to do and how he was really
running our offense our whole offense
was running through him and really has
had to do that since Justin's been out
um the way he was you know Distributing
the football around the field I mean
getting us in and out of plays um really
doing things that kind of was my master
vision for him when I first came here
because I knew he was capable of it and
it would have been awesome to see him
play 17 plus games uh in that you know
in that environment and that with that
kind of comfort and quieted mind that he
was playing with so that's really what
what I felt for the most is for Kirk
just because of all the work that uh
people don't always see I think people
got a glimpse through the Netflix show
but there's so much more to him than
even that uh which I thought was a
really positive uh kind of look into
what Kirk's all about when do you expect
Justin Jefferson to be ready to go yeah
he did a little individual in practice
yesterday and and we'll kind of keep
ramping him up uh look Dan we're going
to make sure uh that he can go out there
and and feel like he's at 100% and be
the Justin that we all know um you know
selfishly you start thinking well maybe
we can just put him in in the red zone
or we can have a package for him there
and uh but the right thing for him and
and and our plans for Justin long term
here in Minnesota we want to make sure
he's good to go uh we want to make sure
he feels like he's been ramped up and
ready to roll and we'll use use this you
know kind of open window to do that kind
of where the bye fell kind of gave us a
little bit of extra time uh that we can
kind of open that thing up and get him
back in walkthroughs and he's been in
meetings he's been around his team the
whole time I mean that's been the
coolest part of a really tough situation
for Justin is just seeing how he's
responded to this adversity and still
been a great teammate he's one of our
captains and you guys can see him on the
sidelines he's never he's never not
around that receiver group he's never
not picking those guys up whenever he
feels like they need to it's been uh
it's been really cool to see I think
he's as I challenged him let's you let's
use this adversity to grow and and come
out better on the other side and he's
done that but there's no question I
can't wait to get him back out there
good luck against the Saints uh always
great to visy with you again Kevin thank
you yeah I appreciate you guys man
that's Kevin oconnell Vikings head coach
uh Vikings are 5- four second place in
the NFC North coming off the win against
the Falcons they got Saint at the
Broncos host the Bears at the Raiders
those are all winnable games then
they're at the Bengals host the Lions
host the Packers uh so